tiscali dottor di oggi ma è un video che
ci avete richiesto tantissimo anche se
oggi merlino e modalità scatenato vuole
andare ovunque lo si chiami tutto è
giocare sempre
comunque oggi faremo il video in cui il
nostro pozzo nel nostro cagnolino
merlino sceglierà gli ingredienti dello
zaino carico presso una cava mito eccola
qua la nostra piccola band si chiama
merlino e oltre quasi quattro metri ma
terzino ora è un pò scatenate ha citato
quindi non so se farà qualche casino
forse serve sicuramente non è che quelli
di vitale apple voglia alla fine del
video voterete steppico io se vincevi
tale imposta la bellezza delle prime ei
suoni smr dell'ort live dei propri
lasciate un bel light se volete vedere
altri video col merlino e amici premiate
il sale volete vedere con questa
formazione e pepe e lasciate un bel
laiche iniziamo subito la salle merlino
birichino ha già capito che non funziona
cosa di pigmenti aiutato la ragione ma
sarà buttato per terra parole piace
bravo il proprio compito e tutto piccola
presi sempre allora scelta numero uno
berlino dovrà scegliere tra con
trasparente o con bianca per farlo
sceglie resi come va sempre zio mi pare
tutto tar cercando i croccantini adesso
metteremo due croccantini una parte e
uno tra e vediamo da fare va per me
se ne sa fare la pole per vitale pronti
un'acqua e una ora facciamo entrare per
vediamo se sceglierà quella bianca tra
spetta pronti
e sparito a scoprire chi sono i
programmi secondo pensava sentito quando
danno vento pizzeria di no vieni ha
sentito l'odore non posso indicarvi di
uno sta sentendo l'odore si è attivato
tra la trasparenza ma anche con la
pioggia
ovviamente li ha mangiati tutte e due
però la prima centre a cosa che farebbe
guidi inizio con la colla trasparente
ecco lo ammetto che la certamente invece
la vita le tocca la colla bianca perché
è stata la sua feconda io ci sono team
giallo vitale non lo avete vinto perché
sto facendo io sono debbo rosso oggi c'è
tantissimo affetto verso per vitale
la vita legge sempre con la bianca come
si che state facendo
datemi le crocchette allora prossima
scelta
mettiamo i nostri colori e con me li
rilancia controllando ha certo e blu ora
secondo a 7 metri notturna sceglie tra
questi colori glitterati vediamo stessi
di il verde per me troppo divertente
vediamo giorni sta sentendo trocchia un
clinic che io voglio entrare vediamo
[Musica]
[Risate]
berlino lascia lascio queste occhioni
scatenatissimo scaletti
allora bravissimo berlino chiesto il blu
per me non lo sconcerto certo siamo un
po come diventa con questo bellissimo
celente come il colore dei tuoi occhi
evitare gli metta in verde cattivo
dovrebbe avvenire nel verde ha colpito
ancora
mi chiamo tanto che bello e un
bellissimo fra in trasparente glitterato
speriamo che si lega bene ancora merlino
volto bello il tuo tempo lui e quindi
serva dai controllate stiamo facendo
bene gli slime è vero noi siamo quella
di evitare come diventa bello verdolino
però vedi è molto chiaro verde pastello
dai carino non è male bello bello dai
vediamo un po cosa altro seggi e ora
merlino o terza scelta abbiamo questi
altri coloranti bianco che non servirà a
molto bella con la bianca rosa blu
abbiamo anche una cosa veniamo questo
egli per meritare poi come col rosso e
celeste l'ascoltatore nel frattempo
quindi io speravo che scegliesse
cellette per me va bene così piccolo che
questa signora g carrozzo chiodi ai
mamma mia che occhioni il controlla come
stiamo facendo la trenza stiamo andando
bene gli ingredienti che ha scelto
allora iniziamo con vitale celeste
glitterato sei stato fortunato questo è
il volturo infatti si tira un bel verde
acqua vediamo queste diventano per
twitter al bravo berlino ha scelto bello
per me
che carino di un bel verde acqua molto
delicato molto carino vediamo il mio che
ha detto hrabal ora spero di no vediamo
almeno c'è chi lo pagherà quelle lo
renderà bello che dia un rosso
trasparente berlino nostro tempo sto
dice noi che cos'è questo rumore stesso
non rumor di coquette tra catene e
lucchetti chi ha o no no no aspetta
violette no no forse diventa viola e
diventano anche piazza abitare il vero
molto bello mi piace to dalla prossima
scelta sono dei pigmenti vediamo quali
segni anche qua silver di qui torniamo
bene oddio vediamo arrivare ma secondo
me li ha presi tutti apprensione per me
il roda ma che cosa che cosa ha preso ma
lascialo siamo dove si sta mangiando
tutto cosi steam i colori che ha scelto
anche se non so come se saranno nel mio
galaxy
questa è una sorta di arancione questo è
un rosso ha parlato che non
era nel tuo verde speriamo bene la
parole siamo un po diventa che per
colore forse sarà davvero un bellissimo
galaxy
vediamo è diventato sotto arancione ma è
comunque bellissimo artico marte wow
tutti bitter mi piace un sacco non vedo
l'ora di hg borno vediamo ora quello di
vitale questo verde acqua e come sarà
con questa rosa che non centra proprio
un bel niente dentro sono stati ha detto
a chi è partito portato che invece sono
dubbioso su questo slide di vita
vogliamo forse lo rende carino perché lo
rende un po per l'altro color terra lo
sto vedendo
oddio forse sta diventando un di colore
che non vorresti che diventa c'è stato
un grilletto proprio appunto per te ma
di berlino ma che cosa c'è vediamo
cos'altro sedie berlino vediamo vediamo
specialmente dobbiamo fissate
velocemente perché lui è fuori che ha
fretta abbiamo i vari glitter questa
volta li mettiamo in cerchio 1234
vediamo che la prendo nota definita e
speriamo non investi finale anche perché
no allora per me st giallo che è secondo
me ci sta bene e per evitare il blu è un
po sbadata che bono jolly vitale lioni a
questi ve ne ricordate
ha portato dove si è nascosto ma prima
maria tentando di perché sentiva da
berlina ci diamo un banchiere il proprio
furbetto è premio sta controllando gli
slime per vedere se li stiamo facendo
bene ogni volta controlla abbiamo
davanti gli ingredienti che assegna non
stiamo parlando allora ecco quelli ter
gialli qui schiavo che bello vedere che
ti parlo proprio un gran a sea group
tempo aranciato come viaggio come detto
questo diventato rosso
vediamo il tool che ben si abbina un po
il colore dei glitter celesti con questo
celestino grigetto allora non ci penso
ma vabbè vediamo una volta attivo come
diventa allora ultima scelta
la schiuma di pedofili gru e la
ricordate
e poi la nozione quindi mettiamo quale
segnerà l'ovazione le schiume di brown
faticaccia robinho bravo
io sono contenta in realtà che non mi
ricapita della schifo perché non so come
sarebbe diventato questo live con la
schiuma mettiamo la lozione si diventa
bello profumato e per vitale mettiamo la
schiuma divertiamoci a freccia farà
berlino rumore incuriosito i papi blasco
di questa pig da mangiare come mino
avevano già tanto allora ecco qua come
diventato il mio slime con la lozione si
è schiarito un pochettino po di bianco
per un buonissimo profumo di fragola
vecchio qualità ne andai
good life sei stato proprio fortunato
con la schiuma partiti bene essendo flop
foto adesso devo mestiere bene chi ha
mischia merlim sta controllando la
situazione sta controllando che stiamo
dando i giusti ingredienti ma sbaglia ma
sta diventando grigio grigio dentro le
nuvolette però grecia george ha detto
nuvole di beta
questo ci rabello plafond non mi ero mai
almeno ci fu la foto anche se un po
grigio celeste parti soliste non
riusciranno meglio in questo che nel mio
provino per me lo dai
allora siamo pronti a vedere come
usciranno una volta attivata e vedremo
chi vincerà tra giallo e tutti in rosso
ma il mio diventato rosso e tuo grido
vero berlino berlino sei pronto vedere
gli spray voti voti tesoro si frutto
ecco qua slime allora alla fine è uscito
un colore un po che fa un po sottotono
consenta berlino ha scelto proprio bene
spero perché prima e la celeste e poi
rosso se n'è uscito questa sorta di
ronza si vedono i glitter e morbidissimo
novati dato purtroppo quindi è un po
poco poco appiccicoso guardate un po
perché ve li sentiamo return severe
l'altra dei sogni fantastici
[Musica]
il tema ecco qua lo slime allora a me
piace un sacco e su quella luca b le
super morbido anche grazie all'adozione
e il colore latini il sito su porcari
rover che rosa con i glitter ovviamente
ancora non si è schiarito perché la cosa
trasparente ci vuole qualche d'oro per
farla sparire
quindi è il live vediamo ora quello di
vitale ma in superficie è un colore
celestino servirsi the flat fee quindi
merlino ha scelto bene anche i colori
del mio dio slime che celestino con
tutti i flakes celesti e di blues o
rivedono e si stanno anche bene eh sì sì
bravo berlino super fuso sentiamo un po
di rumori anche merlino li sta
ascoltando in questi momenti si sta
guardando in si arriva usando con il suo
inizio e r
niente super allungabile forse lo sa
forse ho attivato un po troppo però da è
abbastanza morbidoso ecco allora
vediamoli a fianco e vediamo un po la
consistenza si è abbastanza rapporto tra
il tuo anche un pò lenta si sembra una
nuvoletta brano marino berlino da sotto
addormento magrebino e credetemi se vi
sentite berlino votate votate chi vince
se vi segui il live quello di vitale e
cloud drive scelti da berlino votate qua
nel sondaggio se vince il bis lime o
quello digitale così sicuri nei commenti
che altre sale volete vedere non solo
con berlino ma che altre silence slime
consigliateci tutto nei commenti e non
mi lasciavo cliccare per vedere i nostri
prossimi video cliccate su quella che
preferite
ciao